this uh the problem was he repeated that
same position three times by accident
and it was declared a draw he was
annoyed afterwards fair play to do that
to do the defender great but yeah missed
opportunity for madness yeah and uh in
the meantime we see david's move um just
uh developing with the queen connecting
the rooks on the board
and according to my databases the most
popular move here is actually to play
knight takes knight
they'll go into calculation mode this is
quicker than okay this is how my
opponent will reply to my threat this is
how my opponent will reply and uh they
can work out lines because as you
mentioned it's hard to just feel the
essence of it it's hard to just say okay
this piece belongs there because it
might belong on a certain square but
that might change next move so this is
the reason why uh magnus has delayed
developing his light square bishop
because i must admit before developing
my queen i would be
choosing a square from that one um yeah
it's all moved by move here um the
players plans the players intentions
they might all just change
according to which move the opponent
chooses and that's not too common in
chess usually
you have a long-term plan then you stick
to it you're consistent and you're
rewarded eventually if your plan is
superior to your opponents but no
that's not the case here and uh dude i
was telling us his plan actually by
moving his knight to the edge of the
board black i would be
i'd be scared at this point
i think white's position is so easy to
play with all these weaknesses all over
the bishop on c8 is not moving
so not not super happy with uh
will the king on e2 regret regret itself
but
potentially well i can take a pawn right
now attacking the queen
ah sorry attacking the rook
i have pressure by six side check
yeah bishop a6 check what do i do
probably that's a c4
i guess you want to take here